wir haben heute mein Gott bei dir gibt
auch keine Begrüßung richtig ne nicht
mehr bei mir gab immer hallo Leute eure
und willkommen zu diesem neuen Video
nein hey Leute hier sind wieder Marvin
magnifent und mal m& MS m& MS sind hier
warum h du noch mal eingeladen und
willkommen zurück auf diesem Kanal
Beauty Fashion Lifestyle dafür stehen
wir mit meinem Namen was hast denn Du
hier schönes das ist also ich habe
dieses Jahr schon den syvester
Maybelline J Maybelline New York ich
immer Maybelline New York hei maybell
New York das heißt Maybelline New York
na ja wir haben auf jeden Fall ein ganz
tollen Maybelline Kalender und einen
tollen und natürlich die gehypte
charlotte tilberry ist auch am Start
denn malwanne gibt euch wirklich den
heißesten te was Make-up Kalender angeht
diese drei Kalender haben drei
Preiskategorien
affordable weißt du wie viel du für
welchen bezahlt hast ja ich ho mein
Handy und dann heraus 200 € 200 wasest
gar nicht so teuer ist weil
normalerweise ein Highlighter von denen
schon 50 € kostet so je nachdem was das
für Größen sind interessant ja purish
purish für diejenigen die es nicht
kennen da kann man ganz viele tolle
Marken kaufen so eine kleine
vertreiberseite wie Douglas 119 € und
der ist gerade reduziert nee das ist der
Warenwert 370 € haben die aber auch
komisch gemacht dass sie das da erst
hinschreiben und dann durchstreichen der
ist
ausverkauft
5 also mit welchem fangen wir an wir
öffnen immer alle Türchen gleichzeitig
ein und so mäig und dann vergleichen wir
wow
luxury nim mal den nim mal
[Musik]
dening so oh mein Gott die sieht so
schön von vorne aus oh wow noch gar
nicht gesehen oh wowön Odi Swarowski
hätte das schon wieder 3000 € gekostet
das ist schon sehr schön gemacht vor all
wahrscheinlich da kannst du schön auch
immer was wieder reinpacken ne also
kannst auch als schmuckkäschen benutzen
ja aber habe ich das
Gefühl ach man benutzt es danach
actually als Schmuckkästchen das ist
schon hübsch ne aber sind das D nur 12
Tage 1 4 5 6 7 8 9 11 12 dann macht der
Preis aber auch Sinn ne Produktdetails
12 ach so Vanessa sche h du den nichts
gelernt nun gut okay bist du bereit fürs
erste Türchen Türchen Nummer bist du so
eine geduldige auspackerin an
Weihnachten ich bin eher so die reist
ich bin die reist ja meine Mama packt
alles ganz auf kann man das Papier noch
mal auf neu benutzen und dann wird alles
so richtig langsam die Generation die
noch struggl musste ne
nervt hat nicht gesagt okay ich bin
begeistert türche Nummer 1 bei mir ein
Lippenstift gab es bei dem Silvester
erst ganz spät wir haben hier
transparent Lab oh das ist hydting also
eine Gesichtscreme also bei mir war
shimmerpink drin schön ein Lippenstift
in shimmerpink steh keine Nummer sind
keine Nummer ich würde sagen wir gehen
einfach so ja ne aber man man macht
jetzt wie man will willst du das willst
du das Ziehen das Gefühl und dann klaue
ich dir dein Geschenk auf Charlot freue
ich mich oh wow guck mal die Charlot ist
auf jeden Fall sofort am Start mit walk
of no shame für dich
Schande ist es ein Liquid Eyeshadow oder
Lipgloss ich weiß es nicht also das
sieht ganz klar nach Lipgloss aus toll
toll wunderschön guck mal her das wird
jetzt richtig oh wow wow guck mal die
saftigen Lippen saftig
saftig richtig minzig ich glaub so ein
plumingffekt ja sieht hübsch aus gefällt
mir gut weiter mit tüchen Nummer Z Love
ist es nicht so ein Gefühl von Geschenke
auspacken schon schön ja ich bin ein
bisschen gelangweil das war alles auch
bei Silvester drin also bei mir war
wimperusche drin was war bei dir drin
Marvin ist das das was ich die ganze
Zeit schon haben wollte Dream Code wow
Spray das sprühst du auf deine nassen
Haare und wenn du dann deine Haare
danach stylst und glätest dann sind die
so sind die so alglatt und wenn da
Wasser drauf kommt passiert angeblich
nichts sondern die bleiben glatt das
habe ich auf tiktok gesehen und so das
benutzt ja der Hairstylist von de Kim
Kardashian nein doch Nummer D Nummer D
uh eine andere Farbe hier ist ein pinker
cream eyesadow den kriegst aufs Auge
guck mal hier hast du die volume and
definition mask was ist das für eine
große
Verpackung jetzt fashion weiß du not
giving
praktisches
so wow oh ist das ein
panta ja guck mal sieht schon die sieht
schon sehr cool aus muss ich
sagen eigentlich müssen wir vorher auch
die Wimpern schon biegen ja wow so
Mäuschen mach mich hübsch jetzt kriegst
du hier die tolle was ist das hier Tat
hours benutzen jetzt die tolle Mascara
da kann man eigentlich nichts falsch
machen glaube ich jetzt guckst du
einfach runter hast du tolle Wimpern
mein Gott das ist weil ich Grünen Star
habe D muss ich mir mal Augentropfen
jeden Abend vom Schlafen gehen machen
deine Wimpern oder was mit Hormon ne das
ist das der Wirkstoff der in
wimpernserum drin ist das ist der
Wirkstoff gegen grünen
starch se 18 die
Augen nebenffekt haben ne ich sch das
war es gibt ein nebenffekt deine Wimpern
werden halt ultra lang nicht so okay
okay wow das ist aber schön ich muss mal
kurz gucken was sie kostet na ja
2395 sind wir sind ja hier in unserem so
Mittelfeld
Adventskalender wir schauen jetzt aber
was hier in der dre drin ist hier haben
wir nämlich luxuriös scha mal wie das
hier drin ist dieser Kalender sieht
wirklich halt gorous aus und zwar haben
wir hier das Magic Serum Vanga looking
miracle Skin brauch ich machen das jetzt
einfach mal hier ich weiß nicht ob das
so ein gesichtsprer ist oh jetzt musst
du verteilen weil ich mit Handschuh kann
das nicht einfach mal einarbeiten und
wie führt sich an Reich gibt es dir 200
€ geen Yogastudio also Yogastudio rie
es wollen wir mal schauen ob es ein
weiteres miracle in deinem Maybelline
New York doch es heißt Maybelline New
York tatsächlich das nicht so präsent
kaler wo sind wir ja liiner in das ist
doch toll das passt doch super oh jetzt
geht's los sua ja UV Grun aufmachen son
zerreiß dir
währenddessen nehme ich jetzt mal den
Lipliner und oh der ist ja was ist hier
passiert da professioneller kann auch
damit
arbeiten geen wir du über die L ich geb
dir jetzt
hier so haben abgetragen weiter geht ich
mal immer über die Lippe aber so einen
Make-up Look wie ich habe bekommst du
auf meinem Kanal du bekommst hier jetzt
so ein bisschen so dass du dich auch
noch nach dir fühlst so du hast das toll
geöffnet guck mal also ich bin aber ein
bisschen verwirrt es ist Weihnachten es
ist Dezember woür UV du also wenn du da
jetzt halt vielleicht so ein tannenbauml
schminken willst mit ein bisschen
grünleiner finde ich cool würde ich
sagen h wir jetzt für ein bisschen
später auch falls noch ein lidchatenpukt
kommt weil das würde ich wirklich so let
letzter step ich dachte nee ist kein
Lidschatten machst du nass und dann
kannst du damit Eyeliner ziehenst
schwarz ler gel weiter geht wir haben
keine Zeit mehr wir sind jetzt bei
Nummer 5 oh ich habe ein großes Paket ja
g mitellenwasser cool und Gier im
Maybelline ord ja ich habe Silvester
Ordner war auch schon PST du laut aus
hör gorgeous 100 Liquid hydration Toner
Toner si es ist Nikolaus wir gehen an
unseren Adventskalender und es gibt
bisschen komisch dass keine Zahlen drauf
sindest das Gefühl so das auspack
Gefühlt schön das ist tolles das ist
tolles samiges Papier ne so was ja der
kostet in der normalen Größe 50 das ist
der Easy highlighterack oh ist ein
Concealer nee ist
Highlighter wow
wow ja guck mal hier du oh mein Gott
schön ne okay dann gehe ich jetzt mal zu
Maybelline und guck mal was ich da zu
ncolaus bekommen habe du klingst aber
nicht soorisch
da oha der super
wow superstay mat ink wirklich ich habe
ja auch den Silvester kalalender inim
Kopf und der war so schlecht ich zeig
das auch einmal nach vorne das ist ein
bodyöl ja hair body face das liebe ich
weil ich mag das wenn ich mir z.B so ein
abendkleib anziehe habe ich so von Shen
David und von dir mir abgeguckt und dann
auf dem Körper so Glitzer damit damit
der guck da sehen sie wie schön das
glitzert sehen Sie wie reichhaltig Ihre
Haut aussieht na ja glitzert aber nicht
so ne ich se gar kein Glitzer wow Nummer
s Express brow den hat ich schon im
silvesterkalender Al einfach by s
Lipbalm das ist eine tolle Lippenpflege
mit Lichtschutzfaktor 50 plus woW ist
wichtig auch die Lippen brauchen
Lichtschutzfaktor ja aber komm Summer
ist hier in meinem Kalender für im
Dezember die haben vielleicht do einfach
was aus ihrem Sortiment da reingepackt
in adventsk W Dach müssen wir mal
loswerden hab hab wir doch im som Sommer
weiß ich meine verständnisvoll so e lass
die doch ja
so das Lager muss auch mal gelehrt
werden jetzt nächstes Türchen sind wir
schon angekommen acht du bist halb ne ja
a hast schon aufgemacht kann wasest du
überhaupt ja s habe ich aufgemacht so
ich habe gerade so nerven Zusammenbruch
Moment Express brow warum benutzen wir
den nicht ich habe den ach so nee den
habe ich nicht hey ho let's go du
wolltest doch deine Augenbrauen so nach
oben haben bisschen ja jetzt können wir
mal gucken wie gut der funktioniert
wollen wir die andere noch lassen meinst
du da kommt noch mehr willst du noch mal
ziehen am Türchen und was haben wir
schönes intüchen Nummer 8 lip oil
Crystal Elixir lip oil ist doch auch
gehyped ja das ist schon ganz trocken
hier bei dir kannst mal was drauf machen
hat so kühlingeffekt ja auf jeden Fall
ja jetzt ich merke jetzt
kommt's Vanessa jetzt dreht sich die
Kugel gar nicht mehr so richtig komm
guck mal was da weiter ist Mensch toll
ganz neutrale Farbe was denn passt zum
nude a so braun ja Caramel crush jetzt
haben wir hier Paula choice Paul choice
exfoliate daily Exfoliation soll doch
eigentlich nicht so of benutzen jetzt s
wir bei Türchen Nummer 9 erst Türchen
Nummer 9 ist das beste Türchen we meine
lieblingszah ist ich habe die Theorie
dass Türchen Nummer 9 immer das Beste
ist und ich sag das soangee bis alle
adventskalenderf das ne immer zum besten
hat auf dich gehört denn wir haben
perfect Prime eyadow priming Base
Mikrofaser handsandchuh habe ich wir
haben Lidschatten Primer du hast schon
Lidschatten Primer drauf mikrofaserhchuh
te zum Makeup entfernen wie das auch
aussieht bei
mir so stehst duend in dein Bad so
Nummer ze ach so können wir jetzt wieder
mal hier bei der Charlotte ja so
Charlotte was gibst du uns schönes ein
großes Türchen sehr groß sehr breit aber
hat absolut nichts auszu sagen Pushup
lashes t lashes habe ich schon Charlot
gibt uns eine Mascara die Energie ist
ist jetzt so ein bisschen auf einem nein
die Energie kommt jetzt zurück die
Energie kommt jetzt zurück mit Zeh ich
habe hier nämlich endlich LD kom ma
bisschen bisschen 2017 Vibes oh mein
Gott ich habe die Nummer ze was da wohl
drin ist ich hab auch die Nummer ze ist
ist eine Lidschattenpalette ja oh mein
Gott sind die Farben schön
oh h dieser Kalender ist so viel besser
als der silvesterkalender ich sag's
immer wieder ein Eyeliner guck mal hier
du hast da schon reing gar nicht gemacht
pish Statement warum sind da Löcher
drinin sagt er war es nicht okay ich war
so Maus dann geht's jetzt mal endlich an
den finalen Makeup Blog guck mal wollen
wir Dir doch jetzt mal ein bisschen was
bieten
hier jetzt geht richtig ab jetzt mach
mal hier dein 2012er 14 17 wann war so
dein Make-up Zeit du du Makeup cake face
Zeit oder was ja doch ja ja 2017 habe
ich meine Palette rausgebracht ich muss
sagen die die Zusammenstellung ja ist
halt sehr soft so aber finde ich schön
auch hast du schon was gefrühstückt
heute ich auch nicht oh mein Gott
bestellen wir uns gleich
was oder wie gehen was essen zack ich
verstehe das nicht du Naomi ihr macht
das so krass ihr macht so zwei Sachen
und dann kommt ihr so
raus du hast eine echte Überraschung P
ist so richtig da könte alles drin sein
das finde ich cool bei P weil P halt
auch einfach nur so viele verschiedene
Marken hat und dann hat man halt auch so
ein bisschen so alles das finde ich echt
cool muss ich sagen bei mir in ist schon
wieder Nagellack drin und auch wieder
ein sehr neutraler Ton ja kann man
[Musik]
machen wie findest das
Geräusch ja ist das auch ein störendes
Geräusch Shampoo shine and antifress ich
find ich nice dass ein Shampoo drin ist
muss sagen wir haben jetzt so wir hab
Make-up wir haben Shampoo stabil weiter
geht's 12 geh mal die sch ich ma nebei
weil ich bin schon aufgeregt
Lipliner hab
tol wir haben hier Revolution superdi
Liquid Blush geil den benutzen wir jetzt
schau wie super der ist von Makeup
Revolution glaube ich ne
ja ist das ein
concealere ich kann das nicht weiter
fortsetzen vergessen wir mal ja das war
glaube ich das erste was halt wirklich
jetzt Kacke war ja ich hab den ah fit me
in lila ja hast ein Primer sind wir
schon bei 13 oder was wir sind jetzt bei
13 da kann man schon besseren Anspitzer
geben stat Ofra long lastic Liquid
Lipstick eigentlich genau der gleiche
echt
ist es ist schon sehr gleich so wo sind
wir angekommen 14
erstm Charlot 4 6 8 10 12 14 zack Ei
pencel noch einer hinterher ja ne der
ist jetzt ja für ins
Auge ja jetzt ist er wahrscheinlich
schon gebrochen jetzt kriegst aber gut
jetzt mach mal rein der ist gar nicht so
schwarz schwarz ne der so ein Braun oh
magis wo sind wir 14 ne ja oh oh guck
mal der
XXL hier ich wollte ein
weinroten
Nagellack Nummer ist
weinrot ach der BCE die machen ganz
schön also in dem machen sie aber nicht
so viele Mascara rein sind ja stolz auf
ihre Mascara maybell also du h he deine
auspandschuhe angezogen ja und wir haben
das no Makeup hydration Serum
hyalum was ist deine Meinung zu a Ken
ich
nicht woll esegt aber hast geh wie
wahrscheinlich dieses Geräusch ja nee
ist klar oh baby guck
mal das ist ein Foundation Pinsel ach
echt m kan hier so wollen wir den mal
ausprobieren ja wo ist deine Foundation
ma ein bisschen was auf dem handröen
hier ne ja oh das macht ein bisschen
zarter 16 was ist denn hier los wow die
20 ist ja Ries noch ein Lip Liner ist
okay dieses Mal passen die Farben
wenigstens ein bisschen zueinander guck
mal ich ich habe jetzt hier DM yummy
Skin blurring Balm Powder einfach genau
die gleiche Farbe wie dein Pullover süs
ja schöne Farbe wie fühlt sich das an Öl
es fühlt sich lerally wie Öl an okay
dann mach das mal
drüber das macht die Foundation jetzt
weg ne ist nicht so mein Favorit
okay 18 Charlot haben wir die nicht
schon die 18 oh sheick sheick
ist es noch ein Lippen die hatten do
noch gar kein Lippenstift schöne Farbe
ist das on Brand mit diesem komischen
Leo und dieser Lippe das sieh so ein
bisschen weiß ich nicht diger oh wow
eine Kombi ja so einen roten long lastic
Lippenstift und ein Catrice volizing lip
Booster ist eine schöne Farbe ist warm
ja ja gut gar nicht so rot wie ich
dachte 17 ich sag doch du hast
reingeschissen du bist ja noch nicht mal
bei 18 was machst du komm lass mich mal
wir haben gar keine Zeit dafür okay ein
hagummi von
Maybelline und dann haben wir hier auch
einen expression Kajal Kajal machen die
immer rein aber gut in dem war ja noch
kein K drin sch ich habe auch 17 wir
haben 17 nicht gemacht ja weil du direkt
deswegen weil wir hatten den aufgemacht
den sch dann wolltest du direkt 18
wieder dran ich we haben wir doch gerade
weil wir die 17 ausgelassen haben Saum
mesauda Ken ich gar nicht mesauda ICE ey
pencil in Ruby e pencil ja also fürs
Auge okay dann sind wir jetzt mal mit
der 17 fertig jetzt machen wir mal die
19 toll rechnen können Sie die Youtuber
oh den habe ich schon benutzt der cheiat
FL der ist echt gut s mal ja ist der gut
den machen wir bei dir mal drauf ja aber
ich habe ihn schon den Pack ja toll wir
haben hier in der 19 den
NX honey Lip Balm hier ist der cheekat
ah ja oh Maybelline super super wir sind
stolz auf Dich Nummer 20 wir sind in den
20ern angekommen sind stolz auf Dich
Bruder ich mag das bei P das fühlt sich
an wie Weihnachtsgeschenke es fühlt sich
einfach wirklich an wie
Weihnachtsgeschenke ich habe noch ein
Mascara du gibst mein Produkt gar keine
Aufmerksamkeit das wirkt richtig so als
ob Maybelline gar nicht cool ist doch
das fand ich ja richtig toll jetzt aber
ich war so
fasziniert was zu essen Auspacken weißt
du guck mal wir haben hier ein scrub
down under
W waren wir jetzt 20
ja wieder reiniebst der hier spektakulär
machen wir das
jetzt mat Beauty Blush jetzt haben auch
ein Blush die ne wir wollen jetzt auch
BL jetzt schauen wir doch direkt mal bei
dirg Spann weil das sieht an sich so
dunkler
aush so ja vielen Dank ja Moment doch
jetzt eingearbeitet ach so
klar ja es war ein bisschen
viel also es ist viel Produkt drinne
aber schöne Farbe guckt euch das ab
genauso macht man das ne falls ihr noch
nicht so viel Make-up Erfahrung habt
Marvin zeigt euch das also ganz viel
Produkt drauf machen Toilettenpapier ab
dann noch mal das ist wir nennen es
zuschicht tuschicht face W ganz rot mein
Kopf wer auf jeden Fall freuen in den
nächsten Wochen Charl zu benutzen und zu
tun als ob Dasch
21 ich kann auch nicht
meh Alter jetzt ist schon wieder n aber
jetzt haben wir hier auch die Christmas
Farben ne haben Sie eine gute Auswahl
vier obwohl na ja ich meine die sind ja
auch do vier Nagellack sind toll
undishing tinted Body Lotion in dark
aber ganz ehrlich ich finde so oft
werden für helle Haut Sachen reingemacht
der Maybelline Dings hatte weißen hellen
Concealer also es macht halt schon
verfärbt das jetzt braun wo du es
aufträgst wo sind wir jetzt bei dein 21
du hast dein 21 noch nie aufgemacht
doade aufgemacht ach so
okay Vanessa verliert den Verstand Magic
cream instant turnar
Moisturizer Gesichtscreme süß sieht das
aus wie es so zipfelig ist riecht wie
Nivea Creme sieht wirklich sehr zipfelig
aus
22 ja deine auch bitte wir waren so V
der Charlot begeistert
[Applaus]
beenderleansing
interessant toll 23 ein Tag vor
Weihnachten morgens Weihnachten wir
gehen Kalender tattoiner der war auch
[Musik]
imest das bra ich icheim so komische
Ausschlag was ist das bei Ausschlag so
jetzt gucken wir
was ist das
besonderste nehmen erstm hier
Weihnachten ach ich weiß ja schon was
bei mir drin sein wird es schne es schne
komm alle aus im Haus die wel die weltt
wie bei mir ist die Sky High in uh
glitzi ja Sky High wir haben LH
cosmetics kenne ich nicht
uh komische farbauswah ich ganz
schrecklich bin ich ehrlich also sie ist
sie ist giving Winter ist so
winterpalette aber was macht den dieser
braune eine Farbton da so zwischen also
bin ich ehrlich hab ein bisschen mehr
erwartet die kostet 50 €
50 bei purish ja ich muss sagen ich fand
den ganzen restlichen Kram in im im
purish Kalender cooler ne bin ich raus
da müssen wir jetzt da müssen wir meine
Laune jetzt direkt steigern mit Charlot
tilberry komm es ist Weihnachten wir
gehen an unseren Kalender und es
git Setting
Spray die Größe das ist cool ist auch
eine große
Größe so wie fandst du diesen Kalender
und du ja ich auch welcher war jetzt
dein Favorit ich fand den ich perish
Kalender schon sehr cool hat viele
unterschiedliche Dinge bekommen manchmal
hat man sonst so 15 Lippenstiftfarben wo
denkt davon wieder nur eine hier hat man
so man kann das Gesicht di das stimmt es
ist von allem was dabei aber nichts hat
so wirklich gedoppelt außer jetzt die
lidschadenpalette ja also ich finde
tatsächlich ich hätte lieber ich hätte
eher die in Türchen 24 gemacht und die
dann in in andere weil ja auch wenn die
teurer ist wenn man die so anguckt also
gibt die hier mehr Freude ach so für 120
€ da hast du einfach alles und auch
gerade so Produkte die man einfach neu
Ken also für mich jetzt z neu
kennenlernt wo man mal rumspielen kann
und so GLB das ist wichtig ja finde ich
auch das könen wir das können wir weiß
du was das benutzen wir auf meinem Kanal
das benutzen wir in meinem Youtube Video
wo ich dich Schminke da machen wir damit
noch ein richtig fancy Look geil so ich
so und den fand ich auch cool wenn man
halt Charlot tilbery so Fan ist mäßig da
waren schon coole Sachen drin je Fall
aber jetzt auch nicht so D ich also man
freut sich glaub ich weil auch Charl
tilbery ist aber bei manchen Produkten
dachte ich mir so ja gut also ich mag
die Lipliner voll gerne ich fand
eigentlich die Produkte an sich schon
gut ja und Maybelline ja ich fand jetzt
also ich fand jetzt kein der Kalender
Scheiße nee auf keinen Fall schön schön
dann gehen wir jetzt rüber jetzt packt
ihr mal hier die Sachen pack mal alles
zusammen und dann geht's ab ab zu Marvin
dann kriegst du hier deinen tollen
weihnachtsglam Make-up
Look tschüss Leute tschüss ihr Mausi
macht's gut ne